他说他觉得他也找不到更好的了，
他也就先定下来了，
他现在就觉得他可能还能找更好的，
他才不愿意承认你是他女朋友，
不愿意承认你的地位嘛。
我是想问两个问题，
第一个就是我和我现在的这个对象是不是适合一起以后走进婚姻生活，
第二个就是个人成长的从业方向的一个问题，
我今年是33岁，
他是43岁，
我们都是第二次婚姻，
他有一个娃是14岁，
我有一个娃是9岁，
都是男娃，
全都归前任。
他的娃呢，
他每个月给2500的抚养费，
这个抚养费他一直给到18岁的钱他都存好了，
放在他妹妹那里了。
我的娃呢是当时因为分开的时候是负债的嘛，
没沟通又抚养费，
但是我每年给娃子是报班，
花销大约也在2万左右，
这基本上是定下来的，
他的收入在一万五，
我的收入在1万，
他是做技术的，
合伙，
他现在的公司他有点小股份大约7%，
不多的钱也拿不出来的啊，
我们认识的是一年半，
但是我们基本上是异地，
现在是同居了大约三个月，
平常见面也就周末见面，
因为我们俩上班就在异地嘛，
现在住在他的房子里，
他的房子大约加利息贷款还有70万左右，
这是基本盘，
但是有一个问题，
就是总体来说他是。
一个很负责任的人，
也是一个比较理智的人，
但是你知道有一时候我感觉他有点很淡薄亲情啊，
因为他自己父母就过世了，
我这边父亲也是过世了，
家里也没有托付的，
另外还有一个弟弟，
第二个就是发生了一件事情，
我觉得好像有点过不去，
他欺骗我和前任有点藕断丝连的，
第一个是跟他前前面是一个经济人联系，
因为他之前他出差嘛，
他这个房子就是他前任在把他出租，
他们俩房租对半分，
他告诉我是他俩只有经济联系，
后来我知道了，
但我看他手机，
他俩其实微信联联系，
平常还聊聊天什么的，
这一次为什么我觉得他他欺骗我呢，
是因为物业，
我要加物业的微信群，
后来我认证了，
把他房产证，
身份证都在我这，
我发给物业，
物业呢，
就说我的认证信息不对，
其实物业是没有和他核对，
是和他前任核对的，
因为之前是他前任加的信息嘛，
后来他还在跟我撒谎，
是和他核对的，
后来物业直接打电话过来，
因为物业不知道我跟他在一个空间里嘛，
打电话说他对那个女的和对的女的叫什么名字，
但那种程度才说啊，
他俩还在联系，
还有一个我翻看他的聊天记录，
他跟他前任说现在住在他房子里的不是他的女朋友，
是他的朋友的家人。
我对这点很。
介意的，
为什么不能公开这个事情呢？
他也去过我的家庭，
我也去过他的家庭，
第一个你不和对方说明我是你的女朋友，
就是我不能接受的。
第二个为什么到现在你们俩有联系，
有经密联系，
你如果正常联系，
你就说我也能接受，
而且物业的事情你干嘛都是方便，
罗对罗鼓对鼓了，
你还在欺骗我呢，
这是欺骗，
这两个事情我不能接受，
我就这样跟他讲大约上周六班的事情，
我说你给我一个礼拜的时间，
我要去做抉择，
我是否可以继续等下去，
我是这样跟他回来，
我们俩聊了一次啊，
这是第一个事情，
其实我觉得啊，
本来咱们都是有孩子的，
他也有孩子，
咱也有孩子，
本来都是属于结一趟婚了，
离过一趟婚了，
你要清醒的知道自己想追求的东西是什么，
追求的是使用价值，
因为他给不了我太多的情绪价值，
我调节维度，
包括我买您的书，
我也知道他的使用价值很大，
我说的比较现实啊，
现在我有房子住，
我不用出房租，
房租水电费他也都会给，
还有他会定期的，
因为我做了两份工作，
还做个小兼职，
他都会给做饭，
给弄，
我觉得作为家庭还是我觉得做的可以的，
因为我觉得他的使用价值挺大的，
我是考虑到这一点，
既然他他有的是什用价值，
那他能用就行了呀，
你也不追求他的情绪价值，
你不追。
他对你专一，
感情上对你有多浓厚，
那如果他不欠债，
他没有经济负担，
一月能挣15000，
你一月能挣1万，
完了之后他还给你做饭，
那我闹什么，
有什么好闹的没了，
我很理智，
我不跟他闹的，
我觉得其的梅姐说，
我对你一次婚姻经过感情也没有那么感性啊，
都是很现实的，
他也很现实，
我承认我以前比较感性啊，
我现在还是挺现实的，
不要再轻易生孩子，
如果你要的就是使用价值的话，
能用就接着用，
但我们还是打算要一个孩子，
那我觉得你还是要慎重一点吧，
再观察一段时间吧，
他都不愿意承认你是他的女朋友，
其实我说这个话呢，
嗯，
有点不好听啊，
什么时候他觉得他也找不到更好的了，
他也就心定下来了，
再看要不要生孩子，
他现在就觉得他可能还能找更好的，
他才不愿意承认你是他女朋友，
不愿意承认你的地位嘛，
真的，
人都有一个认识自己的过程，
都有一个自知的过程，
什么时候他觉得他也找不着更好的了，
他可能就定下来了。
对，
我觉得龙芬姐你这点说的很正确，
他自己的解释是他觉得我比他年轻，
他觉得我们俩不稳定什么的，
我其实内心是不认可他这样的说法，
但是我更认可你的说法，
因为他是有点自傲的，
他一路是靠着自己走过来，
有一些小成就的，
他其实这个人是蛮不能说自负吧，
比较觉得我做的决定，
我是比较优秀的，
他是这样觉得，
所以你不能着急生孩子呀，
你得观察呀。
他什么时候定了心了，
踏踏实实想跟你过了，
才能考虑备孕的事儿，
是不是啊，
这一点我明白，
那么就慎重，
生娃的事情我就慎重，
你跟我说的他不承认我这个的这件事情呢，
我也就是能自洽，
因为我之前有点不能自洽的，
对于这个点其实不是觉得，
难道我不够优秀吗？
我一开始就觉得是我自己不够优秀，
嗯，
也解开了，
其实我觉得这个事儿啊，
也是相互的，
那从你这个角度，
你要是能遇到一个比他更好的，
你是不是也考虑换一个样，
会吧，
我压着你，
我又实话实，
我也会因更很现实了，
观察一下，
看是不是两个人都能现在的自己接纳现在的这个状态再说呗，
但是他又催着你这催着要孩子呀，
那其实是他的事，
你自己心里里有谱啊，
因为生孩子这个东西，
他最后帮助的90%的概率还是帮住了妈妈嘛，
所以最终是你要来承担这个结果的，
这个事情一定是你自己拿主意啊，
不要说别人谁催你就怎么样了啊，
对，
为了我想在法律上你给我一点建议，
我想和他签订夫妻财产协议，
因为我们明年打算即时不领证啊，
我们俩都有一个印象，
把钱什么是我们共同用的，
什么是分开用的，
什么是给双方的两个孩子用的这个钱定下来，
我想和他签这个协议，
包括他的房产这一块，
呃，
他以后贷款我们俩领完这个都是共同的负债，
我说我们要占额什么的，
他也同意了，
但是我对这一块。
啊，
我没有一个法律的很懂的，
其实我是想把游戏敲定，
所以说那我想听一下你这块给了一个建议啊，
从规则上来说啊，
你自己婚前的房子，
你自己婚前的财产存款，
这些都是可以写协议也好，
不写协议也好，
他都是你婚前的，
跟他是没有关系的，
你婚前的这些你想怎么处置，
你想留给你的孩子是没有任何问题的，
那么同样的道理，
他婚前的他的房子，
他的车，
他婚前的财产，
他想留给他的孩子也没有任何障碍的。
法律上，
但如果一旦你们俩领了结婚证，
从领结婚证那天开始，
你们俩赚的钱都叫夫妻共同财产，
比如说他愿意给他的孩子2500，
你愿意给你的孩子一年花2万，
这都是在你们的这个责任范围之内的，
这都没问题，
那么剩下的跟是你们夫妻的共同财产，
那你们要花钱的话，
要有大的开销的话，
是要相互商量着来的，
是要通知对方的，
对，
就我们已经商量好，
我们想把协议签下来，
因为我看了您的书嘛，
我们俩是打算，
比如说每个月拿出工资的，
每个人的占比的30%，
那存在一起，
其实我们俩可共有的就是这些嘛，
这也没问题，
比如说我们俩用于家用的是多少，
再拿出百分之多少就是家用的，
还有一部分放在一级的，
其他的钱就是比如说给双方孩子，
我们沟通好，
比如说花多少钱以上我们是需要沟。
不的，
以下我们是自行不沟通的，
我不是这样，
我初步概念是这样的，
我不知道这样可以合不合理，
这样合理，
我俩不管你挣得多也好，
我挣得多也好，
我俩拿出一部分作为我们共同将来养育孩子，
或者说我们共同的家庭开销，
这都是合理的，
没有任何问题。
但是因为怀孕和生产这个风险是你在承担的，
所以我觉得呢，
如果真的要结婚的话，
还是得要一笔彩礼作为你的婚前财产，
我们商量好了，
我要的不多，
大约几万块钱，
那就这个也沟通好了，
没什么问题啊。
还有一个就是我个人成长，
因为就像罗菲姐您说的，
我在以后假如备孕生产这一块，
我的工作可能因为不适合就不适合做了嘛，
我不知道我两个方向，
我是做哪两个方向啊，
第一个呢，
我一直在关注您的切片，
其实我很想去做，
也在了解，
也加群了，
但是没有落地下来，
我这个行动力我觉得我是不够的，
我已经呃关注了您这件事已经大约两周了啊后还有一个事情，
我这里是个人非常爱做美食，
对于做美食也是营养是特别感兴趣，
因为还有对于平常身体的锻炼，
做力量这一块，
其实我一直在做，
我不知道是我是朝这个方向，
是做营养运动这一块方向去做呢，
还是说两者都可以同时做，
还是说以后经营自己的代替账好，
因为我觉得这个如果我是这样做的话，
以后在我备孕营生产，
甚至前几年带娃的过程中，
可能我也不会中断我的经济。
源了，
我觉得营养这方面是大的方向，
就是营养搭配啊，
营养餐食啊这方面是大的方向，
包括营养师啊，
这个方向都是挺好的方向，
但是我觉得做自媒体的话，
最终还是要落脚到自己身上，
还是要落脚到自己的形象，
自己的IP，
自己的输出，
就像很多做我的切片的姐妹们，
他们不出镜，
他光捡我的这个切片的话，
如果有一天她自己在直播间直播想要卖货的话，
他确实有一定难度，
因为大家要认点的，
所以我还正好就是建议所有自己做切片的姐妹啊，
最好是你自己也露脸，
你剪一剪呢，
剪到我说的话的时候，
你自己讲一讲你的心得呀，
体会呀，
讲一讲你的故事啊，
讲一讲你的这事情的看法呀，
还是要是认你自己这张脸的，
我觉得是这样，
那我明白了，
好，
那就这样好，
我自己的东姐啊，
起嗯，
再见样啊，
对所有做切片的姐妹，
不管你的粉丝已经做到了三千五千还是一万两万的啊，
最终你要想变现的话，
你觉得还是要认你的这张脸它才长久啊，
记得点赞关注哦。